diese geschichte beginnt mit einer
uralten frage was erwartet uns nach dem
tod grabesstille ist der rest schweigen
oder sind die toten weiter unter uns
wären sie gar mitteilsam
aber ihnen fehlen die ansprechpartner
unter den lebenden
[Musik]
pascal voggenhuber sagt er sehe
verstorben und könne mit ihnen reden
dass er mehr waren als andere ist sein
beruf
[Musik]
ich hab's ganz alt also dass wenn ich
jetzt irgendwie im coop an der kasse
stand und jetzt liegen wir weiß nicht
die verstorbenen mutter von grund vorne
trat zu mir und als anni aschoff ich
habe wirklich seite und ich sagte ich
hätte nicht mit dem körper botschaft
also sagen dass seine verstorbene genau
und zu akzeptieren
aber wieso im supermarkt rumstehen wenn
man auf einer wolke sitzen könnte
es interessiert sollte weiterhin noch
wie rankel oder wie gut oder wie geht's
mit meiner tochter also eigentlich nur
wenn er demut text steht in die
kreisstadt ist sie noch nicht nur die
also mehr an dem es steht dann ist man
im handel oder und persönlichkeit von
einer person die blieb
[Musik]
der dialog mit verstorben ist ein
handwerk das gelernt sein will
zum beispiel in der berner
effingerstrasse hier drückt die
voggenhuber nach einer
schauspielausbildung fünf jahre lang die
schulbank
[Musik]
sie sehen richtig hier werden keine
vokabeln gepaukt hier üben die schüler
wurde klasse den austausch mit toten
[Musik]
das ist holz starkes auto mit dritt
klargemacht dass sie die lehrerin loggt
sich in den gleichen wundersamen kanal
ein und überprüft die arbeit der schüler
also habe ich das gefühl dass wir immer
nur bissig oder den eigentlichen auch
gold rush das verstauen und das wirklich
verstehen was haben wir jetzt so genau
was ist da passiert ist im grund zu
demonstrieren nennt man das mit quasi
ein stück weit so genau beschrieben
wissen dass nur eine person im publikum
castro
es gibt verschiedene möglichkeiten es
geht sache wohl nicht
also wo mir zeigt wertsachen wo man
fühlt oder wäre das ohne jetzt
ambitionierte peters mir sache also das
möchte mich beim namen das datum gehört
und so spielt sehr philips gefühl als
todesursache meinem körper spüren
außerdem bildet das ein wenig zeigt
weder der bezeichnet wird die person
muss zeit nach dem unterricht will ich
von der schulleitung wissen wie der
mittlerweile 28-jährige erlebe den
geraten sein dass man ein rohdiamant
quicktime und jetzt ist es ein diamant
wo viele griffen sie und viele vater
grob erkennbar sie und viele vor seite
sicher stehen auch stehe oder werde
zeige aber diamant wo man schon der
klare wörthersee wo schon wieder
strahlen
schönbach im kanton schwyz hier lebte
miriam ziegler bisher weg nach nur 25
jahren endete
seither ist es ruhig geworden im haus
sagt miriams mutter ein jahr ist
vergangen und miriam ist irgendwie immer
noch das leben war geprägt durch
krankheiten ein gen defekt führte zu
massiven übergewicht später war sie für
monate ganz körperlich gelähmt hatte
eine lungenentzündung
sie ist die jüngere schwester
organisierten ihr leben um ein zentrum
besonders macht
alwin ziltener baut stellwerke für die
sbb lisbeth ist kindergärtnerin die
familie stand mit den füßen fest auf dem
boden
trotz allem bis miriam überraschend ins
koma fiel
die vielen offenen buch es ist so viel
kapuze und sie haben diese ganz korrekt
das gwk sieht und das management legte
mit enormen schäden simone glaube nicht
dass mir die maschinen abstellen und das
wie sie damals ist mir sagen wie
glücklich sie mehr lesen sie mal was
gemacht
und dass man sie hat verdient versuchen
ihn stärken
wie hätte da wieder abschieben doch das
nehmen was ihm später hoch sich und
informatiker interessiert und arthur wie
hat sie es oft rannten sie denn
eigentlich ist der 08 trainer auf der
bank
das hat die sache beschäftigen dem
omanischen stadt
[Musik]
ich war zählt einfach viel was ich
sicher heben und dass sie einfach
rumänischen wer darf auf meinen schulter
modus ist hat maxi und zustellung ist
jetzt auch und will alles was ich kann
das wichtigste sei nicht gänzlich
verzichten dies ist ein moment dass gott
ist das ist aus dem 420 tag und dann
nach dem krieg sparen schon ausgesuchten
beispiele dass das ich dass sie die
nacht wäre nach und bietet dazu sagen
wenn ich dann den urlaub wenn jetzt das
machen oder wenn jetzt tausende machen
oder wenn wir den donnerstag umziehen
miriam ist gestorben aber anscheinend
nicht verstummt sie sendet durch pascal
voggenhuber nachrichten sind zehnter was
überzeugt doch dazu später mehr
ist die vorstellung dass sich die toten
durch leute wie voggenhuber mitteilen
sollen bizarr oder tröstlich ich frage
mich ob ich selber durch ein medium mit
einem verstorbenen reden wollte
vielleicht gebe es ja einiges zu
besprechen
nur wie glaubwürdig ist der trockene
wäsche kanal ins jenseits überhaupt ich
begleite ihn am samstagabend in sich
sacher papphocker und frage leute die
ihn kennen zb seine ex-freundin 7
und es ist einfach zu sagen unsere
kunden und heize club für die anstieg
weiß nur einmal und ich glaube der einst
für den ersten mal jähren übernachtet
haben bin jetzt macht mal aufwachen wenn
ich glück habe ich ins templiner klaffe
noch nicht am markt zurück seither immer
einfach
joachim freund dann irgendwie nicht so
cool gefunden und denn als ich seine
technik haben wir morgen teilt
rückfragen sie sind es in erster linie
und dann klappt nachruf ist weder
passiert das immer wieder einmal den
klubs nach der musik von der das ewige
stadt nicht groß mit schwarz nachdem ihn
nach oben mit vergnügen haben offenbar
alle bereits sonderbares erlebt und
finden das mittlerweile ganz normal
ganz überraschend mini alter schlüssel
vom schaft quasi durch verstorbene seit
monaten ist das gang eines geschäfts
größeren oder hat es auf der baustelle
schafft und den han i morgen die
schlüssel gefunden und hat einen
durchaus möglichen zusammengeschweißt
hat weil ihr das paar bei den vermögen
seit ihr jetzt wunsch unbedingt oder
wenn man die haben die ganzen geschlagen
hat der schlüssel gefunden und da hat
man wolle das ist noch nicht geschrieben
oder schlüssel ist und weil möbel
einfach zu und stand auch dass daraus
eine bestätigung gehe das showbiz
training ran
senator schlüssel zu finden wo niemand
kennt gussteile von schlachtvieh ist
sozusagen energien schleich dich kriege
dienstleistung noch genau das gleiche
er hilft er lügt in dem regener antworte
geht vielleicht und dienstleistung
[Musik]
klappt man muss es erlebt hat dass man
es war wirklich glaubt glauben dass
voggenhuber tatsächlich tote sehen und
mit ihnen reden kann immer und überall
also vermutlich auch hier und jetzt
mitten unter uns an diesem samstag abend
im pub
[Musik]
wenn ich bei hofer hat wenig keine tote
22 birgt das lief los die medialität
braucht extrem viel konzentration also
das ist wirklich wichtig wenn man muss
ständig man sich das so vorstellen muss
zu hause was mir die klient verzeiht ich
muss zu hause was die geistig wald
verteilt und die er kommuniziere wird
viel über score und über bildet und das
braucht extrem viel aufmerksamkeit oder
das ganze zu verbinden und tatsächlich
schwierig selbst wenn dies tatsächlich
möglich wäre
sollten wir die verstorbenen nicht
trotzdem gehen lassen für immer wieso
die pforten zu den erinnerungen an sie
immer wieder aufstoßen wurde nicht mit
tiefer weisheit ein schleier über das
jenseits gezogen
pascal voggenhuber wohnt bei seiner
mutter esther in sich zusammen mit
seiner hündin luna wie erklärt sich
esther wochen über die angeblichen
fähigkeiten ihres sohnes und weniger das
mit versteuert und gilt als ebenso
geschichten auf praxen aber allerdings
mine sind die geschichten erzählt aber
für mich sind realität sie und darum ist
für mich gar nicht so
ein spezielles gesehen also versuche ich
das passt
das ist klar will ich weiß es ehrlich
und offen ist und nicht will kunden an
der seitenlinie energie zurück also
nicht einfach nur versucht ganz machen
sondern wirklich dann die zweifel ob der
kleine pascal wohl mit verstorbenen
redete während die anderen knirpse im
sandkasten buddeln
der stärkere dollar hat auch schon im
bett erzählt dass otto b im zug sich und
ich hatte eine menge zeitung war heißt
doch einfach schlecht 33 länder und
andere stehen eigentlich zum park hin
dass im team zu plötzlicher komponiert
hat der firma beinhaltet so was meine
stimme sehr praktisch weil der
rosenallee prozent hat dass sie eltern
habe werde ich eine kollegin hat hans
bertram mx damals noch seit der hand
special ab dem 26
und wenn ich doch da und ist in mein
geschäft nachrichten nur eine der liegt
ganz konkret sei daran dass jetzt
niemand dem handwerker aus
es sei wieder einmal zeit für ein thema
wo mit miriam sagen zehnter das also
besuchen sie locken huber in seiner
praxis in ittingen beisitzer ist kein so
machen nun selbst zweite maxi dass ich
habe gleich am anfang probierte barbies
ski völlig wo nichtraucher sind oder wo
sich inzwischen zieht ereignet hat
aber so dass mir be oder alle drei
sicher sind dass sie wirklich okay okay
was ist ihre köpfe zählt oder was ein
recht spannende ist dass wir nachts fest
und sie seit wir nach der bei euch der
hype wird ist das richtig und das ist
das eigentlich nicht an weil er machen
zuerst ok und sie seit ich bin so
dankbar dass es klick gemacht hat und
sie ich bin dogmatisch sieht dahinter
trat fensterfront auf eine längst statur
gemacht hat sind sie seit ich bin
wirklich dort gesehen da kein jetzt soll
es also passieren nachrichten von miriam
sie erzählt dass du irgendwie die letzte
woche dass die situation hätte dem
abitur 8ku fräger noch das sind die
letzten die vorletzte woche das gefühl
wird dass irgendein job sie zudem auf 10
uhr verliehen hätte
ich dachte nur für hektisch wenigkeit
also gar nicht und das ist eben schon
mit der zeit aber irgendwie bietet das
tool in bahnen darunter selbst einige
druck machen sie beschnitten chef also
das ist okay
macht sinn dass ich nie verantwortet und
sie seit das gut out room
das unternehmen sei das ist das limit up
stand alone gemacht sie da sagen dass so
viel zeit dass nutzer fotos seiner
lebens machen die locken sie möchte
sagen mach du das jetzt bitte was ist
jedoch ausschließlich von ist - bild
trotz seiner ganzen breite eisberg im
unterschenkel und links ist es richtig
dass er mit der band zeigt dass dort ab
ich bezüglich und das durch das aber wie
eine verrückte oder das ist okay aber
seine zeit verstanden ist dass sie
gezeigt dass sie körperlich jetzt sehr
viel trauerarbeit beim psychologen kampf
erzählt anders nicht in farbe eine
selbsthilfegruppe schon er diese eher
übrige sich nun aber dank nuber das ist
viel besser gut also dass wirklich der
tumor schmucks frauen-achter schritt
könne mache und das ist so eine
das heißt dass freud wiso mein sehr
unterschiedlicher mit über und macht sie
natürlich traurig weil sie nicht
wirklich direkt von oder trophy
geliefert
an dem morgen nur froh sein
[Musik]
aber ich denke dass genau das gleiche
wie wir bitte wir nach der note das
einfach nur dass sie nicht zu fest
offizier sondern einfach sagt das was
ihr denn was passiert ihnen wenn sie da
sind und dass die mit ihrer tochter
also ich finde ich dieses komisches
gefühl und das was er gesagt hat
vom schaftlichen stimmt oder nicht ist
einfach wohl und chris gefühl dass sie
deutsch aber dass die wirklichkeit
bestätigen dass sie wieder in diesem
quartal nimmt das ist ein punkt den man
mal gut
sie ist nicht mehr zeit ist dass sie
wirklich ein riesentalent mehr aus mir
deshalb wären aber sicher us-dollar und
das interessiert mich dass die tür
öffnet erweise oder ist das wichtig für
sie das ist kulanz und sich ein teil von
mir erwarten und nämlich nicht wenn es
ums leben
und wahrscheinlich schon punkten
medizinisch weißt du ich bin zwar in
zahlreichen es alleine machen alles aber
sie ist jedoch nicht ganz
also es ist nicht ganz so weite teile
vom irischen oder haben jetzt nämlich
wichtiger
die toten und die lebenden angeblich so
nahe beieinander aber ohne möglichkeiten
zur verständigung mit anderen worten ein
riesiger markt für mediale dienste die
bei voggenhuber 160 franken pro stunde
kosten
damit liegt er irgendwo zwischen den
tarifen eines psychologen und denen
eines psychiaters klar und das geht es
immer aber ist schluss sagt zu mir noch
nie einen grund hätte das gefühl zu
besitzen scharlatan oder ja noch nie
gehört vielleicht seid ja wegen der
hindu richtigen scharlatan
ich denke man muss einfach ab jetzt
realistisch gesehen und findet immer gut
wenn man viele sitze geht dass man mit
musik von mir will befragung findet man
sicher bei uns friedlich sie sind aber
bleibt der unterschied ist aber nach wie
unsere beruf sport wenn wir jetzt das
medium schafft oder als heiler schweren
fehler nicht und kann dort halfen ihm
sofort scharlatane
aber wenn du zum beispiel ein arzt oder
rechtsanwalt
sein fall nicht positiv abschließen
sollte der patient nicht einfacher die
jury entscheidet dann
zurück in schübelbach im kanton schwyz
[Musik]
zurück bei peter das zurück am langen
tisch vor der fensterfront dort wo
weihnachten gefeiert wurde das erste mal
ohne miriam aber irgendwie doch mit ihr
laut voggenhuber was sagen sie etwas
kühl und der sich daraus ein humbug
irgendeine schule zauberin schwindel mit
dem prinzip friss muss aber das prinzip
seiner tour durch städte oder magersucht
und der wagen überholt und damit der
studie fest dass der code also ich meine
mädels monats verbraucht und was da
abgegangen zudem sehen will auch keiner
sagen können ich weiß nicht woher und
dann muss ich habe bisher viele
verstehen das natürlich nicht das ist
ganz klar ich muss es wirklich sauber
bleibt unsere zusammen verarbeiten
so endet diese geschichte wie sie
angefangen hat nämlich mit der uralten
frage was erwartet uns nach dem tod
ich habe keine antwort gefunden
chiltern us schon eine antwort
geboren aus den wünschen und hoffnungen
trauer eltern oder sind es die augen der
leidenden die am offensten sind für die
wahrheit
[Musik]